the all-new playstation plus is a
service made of three membership plans
each offering a wide selection of games
for all tastes to download or stream
here's everything you need to know
kicking off with playstation plus
essential for 9.99 a month or 59.99 for
the year you get a number of benefits
including online multiplayer exclusive
discounts in the playstation store all
important cloud storage for your saved
games the ability to share your games
online with your friends using share
play
and monthly games to add to your library
if that's not enough you also get access
to exclusive skins and in-game items for
a number of games like call of duty
warzone and fortnite
for playstation 5 owners you get extra
benefits on this plan including access
to the playstation plus collection a
library of some of the very best
playstation 4 exclusives and third-party
hits prepare for god of war ragnarok by
playing god of war gather your party and
hunt giant beasts in monster hunter
world or take back janam in bloodborne
there's something for everyone in the
playstation collection from horror
thrills like resident evil 7 biohazard
to family friendly games like ratchet
and clank and crash bandicoot and sane
trilogy playstation 5 owners can also
take advantage of game help if you get
stuck in a game that supports game help
you can tap the playstation button to
pull up hints to help you progress these
hints are not only made in conjunction
with the game's developers but they're
also made explicitly to avoid any
spoilers you might encounter if you
search for tips online you can even pin
video walkthroughs to the side of the
screen to give you extra help while
playing if you're already a playstation
plus member your membership will
automatically transition into this plan
next up is the playstation plus extra
plan which provides all the same
benefits as the essential plan as well
as access to the game catalog a
frequently updated library of hundreds
of playstation 4 and 5 games that you
can download and enjoy there's something
for everyone on game catalogue including
playstation studios hits like ghost of
tsushima and marvel's spider-man miles
morales get to the bottom of celine's
mystery in return or duke it out against
punishing bosses in demon souls that's
not all there are a number of games from
third party studios included two from
last year's bombastic marvels guardians
of the galaxy and open world adventures
like rockstars red dead redemption 2 and
kojima productions death stranding to
innovative indies that'll keep you
saying just one more run like dead cells
and even the latest sports games like
nba 2k22 the game catalog also includes
ubisoft plus classics a selection of
beloved games from popular ubisoft
franchises explore 9th century england
in assassin's creed valhalla escape
vass's clutches in far cry 3 classic
edition or take to the roads with your
friends in the crew 2. new titles will
be joining the game catalog regularly
with some games like stray from
annapurna interactive even joining the
collection on launch day playstation
plus extra is 14.99 per month or 99.99
for the year and finally playstation
plus premium this plan includes all the
benefits of playstation plus essential
and extra but also adds a number of
additional ones including game trials
with game trials you can try out a
number of games including cyberpunk 2077
uncharted legacy of thieves collection
and even eloy's latest adventure horizon
forbidden west if you decide to buy a
game after playing the trial any
trophies and save data you have will
transfer to the full game if free games
every month and access to the game
catalog aren't enough for you the
playstation plus premium plan also
includes access to over 300 additional
games thanks to the classics catalogue
you can download and stream games from
past playstation generations including
the original playstation ps2 ps3 and ps4
titles if you want to take your games on
the go you can also stream and play
select ps4 games from the game's catalog
and certain games from the classics
catalog on your pc with the premium
subscription
your saves will even transfer to the
cloud meaning that when you get back to
your home console you'll be able to pick
up right where you left off get all of
this with playstation plus premium for
17.99 a month or
119.99 for the year so there you have it
everything you need to know about the
new playstation plus for more details or
to sign up head over to playstation.com
for more on the latest games make sure
to keep your eyes peeled on gamespot